hi guys in this video we're gonna talk
about the fifth body type what is the
fifth body type well you have the
adrenal which is high levels of cortisol
that's a stress hormone you give the
thyroid body type which is low levels of
the thyroid hormone t4 or t3
okay that gives an overall weight gain
in the entire body this one is more of a
stacking belly then we have the ovary
type that's like a pear shape it's
everywhere around the hips the thighs
the lower but that is high levels of
estrogen okay then we have the liver
which is more of a protruding basketball
belly that is liver damage and then
you're going to have low growth hormone
okay and what's the fifth the pancreas
high insulin it's insulin resistance
okay now this is what's confusing a lot
of people are a mixed body type and they
have various symptoms but there's a much
easier way to figure out your primary
body type but more than that the primary
cause of your body type okay the trigger
for example the body shape for the
adrenal can look identical to the
pancreas body shape but because from two
different things this is stress
triggered let's say you had surgery you
had trauma you had an accident you had a
divorce you had years of being in a very
stressful situation and then you got fat
because of high cortisol okay that could
be the trigger for your adrenal body
type or let's say you ate a lot of sugar
or refined carbs and ate a lot of
frequent meals that could also give the
same adrenal body type appearance
sagging belly weight in the midsection
so just by looking at the outside of the
body you can't really tell what's
causing the problem it could it be
stress related
it could be food related so let's take
the liver of body type what could cause
that fatty liver cirrhosis inflammation
of the liver like hepatitis which could
come from a virus
to come from being an alcoholic but you
can also have non-alcoholic fatty liver
disease which comes from insulin so this
can give you this body shape right here
okay and then as far as the ovary body
type this usually comes from
environmental estrogen like the
chemicals and the GMO foods the
pesticide the insecticides herbicides it
could come from birth control pills or
something in the environment that mimics
estrogen that then gives you this shape
right here and then we have the thyroid
body type which is waking all over but
this is usually secondary to high levels
of estrogen which can then lower the
thyroid or you can have liver damage and
then the thyroid can't convert t4 to t3
so it could come primarily from the
liver and cause the thyroid issue so
really the question is when did you
start becoming this certain shape and
have these certain symptoms and what
happened just before that event and
that's going to tell you like the more
important thing that goes beyond the
body types of the trigger so you can
undo it was it a stressful situation was
it a surgery was it a divorce whatever
was it a sugar situation in which case
you're gonna you know fix the diet get
the basics in was it some chemical
environment and called endocrine
disrupters that you need to start
consuming a lot more cruciferous to
clean that up or was it alcohol in which
case you have to stop drinking alcohol
was it a certain medication let's say
you're on steroids there I have certain
videos and what to do if you've been on
steroids how did it reverse that damage
or was it coming from a virus a virus
can destroy the liver it could also mess
with the thyroid so you really want to
think beyond just the body types
now cortisol estrogen and insulin are
the three fat making hormones they're
dominating hormones in the presence of
any one of these you're gonna nullify in
block all the fat burning hormones
okay one of the fat burning hormones
would be t-43 that's the thyroid hormone
another big one would be human growth
hormone so if these are too high these
will be suppressed so that's why the
thyroid and the adrenal are usually
secondary to these other ones does that
make sense
because these are dominating now out of
these three this one insulin is the most
dominating so in reality this would
probably be the most common body type
but you can also look like this you
could look like this and you can even
look like that because of the influence
of insulin on these other glands
so in summary just isolate when your
problem started okay with your body
shape and these other symptoms and try
to find out what triggered it was it
stress was it diet was it something in
environment with alcohol was there
medication was there an infection and
that will give you the clue to reverse
and undo your specific body type
hey if you enjoyed this video press
subscribe and I will definitely keep you
updated